welcome to the david pakman show i am
farron cousins from ring of fire
sitting in for david pakman today and
might i also say
happy reinstatement week right
because coming up at the end of this
week august 13th isn't that the day
that the conspiracy theorists tell us
donald trump
might be reinstated as president so
you know i guess we have that to look
forward to as well
of course mike lindell my pillow ceo who
david
uh had a wonderful interview with this
past week if you haven't seen it please
check it out
uh he had originally said august 13th
could be the day
he has since kicked the can down the
road a little bit
maybe it's september he tells us maybe
it's even after that who the heck
knows at this point but one thing is for
certain
the department of homeland security is
certainly taking all of this
very seriously late last week
the department of homeland security
actually sent out notices
to state and local law enforcement
offices throughout the country that said
this
dhs is providing awareness of reports
regarding an increasing but modest level
of activity online
calling for violence in response to
unsubstantiated claims of fraud related
to the 2020 election
and the alleged reinstatement of former
president trump
as public visibility of the narrative
increases we are concerned about more
calls to violence
reporting indicates that the timing of
these activities may occur during august
2021
although we lack information on specific
plots or planned
actions so homeland security says right
now and they've been saying this for
a couple months in case you haven't been
following that story
listen we have seen what these
individuals are capable of we saw it
on january 6th when they get worked into
a frenzy
based on lies and misinformation we've
seen what they're capable of doing
and over the months since january 6th
they've been pushing this conspiracy
that somehow someway trump's going to
get reinstated
so what happens when that doesn't happen
see that's what they're worried about is
what happens when the conspiracy theory
proves to be totally false
right trump is not going to be
reinstated as president
on august 13th or at any time
unless he wins a future election and
that's not reinstatement that's winning
an election
but either way people are going to be
angry
people who have been led to believe
these things
we don't know how they're going to react
and that is what department of homeland
security is saying
they have seen what they believe to be
threats of violence online
however there's been no specific
indication of where
when how or even really if it's going to
happen
you know a threat is one thing an actual
plan is a totally different thing
and homeland security is just basically
telling everybody
be on the ready and that's a terrifying
thought
right we don't want to have to live our
lives with this kind of fear of what's
going to happen
when the trump people don't get their
way when these cultists
realize that their conspiracy theories
are totally false
we shouldn't have to live with that but
unfortunately right now this is a
reality that far too many of us well not
far too many all of us
have to accept here's another thing too
and i've talked about this in in videos
on my other channels but
you also have the judges okay the people
hearing the cases listening to
these defendants who were arrested as
part of the january sixth capital riot
and the judges have flat out told us
these individuals learn nothing these
individuals are likely to do this again
because the same kind of lies and
misinformation that got these people
worked up in the first place
they're still out there
and these judges are trained
through years and years of experience
to recognize what a so-called repeat
offender
looks like they look at the psychology
they look at the behavior they look at
mannerisms for god's sake
and they see it as they have told us
with some of these individuals
and we've also had at least one judge
come out and say i'm afraid these people
are getting off too lightly
for what they actually did that day and
therefore will definitely not learn a
lesson and these are people we're going
to have to keep watching
because they're likely to do it again
and that's what homeland security is
trying to tell us
nobody wants to live in a police state
trust me
but they're concerned that what happens
this weekend
when trump doesn't get reinstated could
be very bad
for the country if you ever feel like
you just
don't have enough time to read all the
books you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular non-fiction books
and distills each one down into an
e-book
or audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from 10 different
books
in an afternoon obviously it's perfect
for exposing yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories
and a subscription is only about eight
bucks a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get
twenty five percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com slash pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video